[Musik]
Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Nächste Woche ist schon Muttertag,
am 09. Mai nämlich dieses Jahr.
Manchmal trifft es sogar zu,
dass Muttertag und der Geburtstag meiner Mama auf einen Tag fallen,
denn sie hat am 10. Mai Geburtstag,
aber dieses Jahr ist es einen Tag vorher.
Ich habe mir gedacht,
zu diesem Anlass backe ich noch eine Muttertagstorte,
die ganz einfach nachzubacken ist.
So sieht sie aus.
Es ist eine Herztorte
und sehr lecker gefüllt, sehr hübsch dekoriert, wie ich finde.
Sie sieht vielleicht sehr kompliziert aus,
gerade mit diesem Drip, also mit dieser Schokoladenglasur,
aber ich finde, sie ist eine richtig einfache Torte,
die ihr nachmachen könnt.
Am Sonntag gibt es dann übrigens noch eine Torte von Murat.
Er backt nämlich auch eine Muttertagstorte.
Ich bin am Muttertag
- das könnt ihr euch vielleicht vormerken
am 09. Mai bin ich im ZDF-Fernsehgarten
und backe dort live noch eine Torte.
Also ganz viele Muttertagstorten.
Aber wie gesagt, dieses Jahr diese Herztorte von mir.
Ich zeige euch gleich, wie ich sie backe.
Ich habe im Inneren einen Biskuit
- der lässt sich nämlich sehr schnell backen,
besteht auch nur aus vier Zutaten.
Das ganze andere drumherum
– es dauert wirklich nicht länger
als etwa 45 Minuten Zubereitungszeit.
Das, was am längsten dauert, ist die Kühlzeit.
Aber so von der Zubereitung her
– ganz locker, bekommt ihr an einem Vormittag hin!
Ich starte jetzt einmal mit dem Biskuit und zeige euch die Zutaten.
Dafür nehme ich 4 Eier, die sind bereits zimmerwarm,
100 g Zucker, 1 Prise Salz, etwas Vanilleextrakt und 100 g Mehl.
Den Ofen habe ich bereits auf 180°C Ober-/Unterhitze vorgeheizt.
Ich gebe jetzt die Eier in die Rührschüssel.
So einen Biskuit mache ich immer sehr gern,
wenn es einmal schnell gehen muss,
weil er aus nur wenigen Zutaten besteht
und eben schnell gebacken ist und auch sehr schnell abkühlt.
1 Prise Salz, Zucker ist darin, Vanilleextrakt.
Jetzt ist im Prinzip einfach nur wichtig,
dass der Biskuit, also diese Eierzuckermasse sehr lange gerührt wird,
für 10-15 Minuten, bis sie schön luftig und cremig ist.
[Musik]
Wenn ihr dann schön geduldig seid,
sieht jetzt die Baiser-Masse so aus.
Jetzt den Schneebesen nicht an der Rührschüssel abschlagen,
denn sonst schlagt ihr die ganze Luft wieder heraus,
die ihr mühsam eingerührt habt.
Dann das Mehl dazu sieben.
[Musik]
Hier habe ich jetzt schon einmal meine Herzbackform.
Sie ist so wie mein Backring, praktisch ohne Boden
und ich kann das Ganze hier auf einem Backblech backen.
Das Backblech sollte eben sein.
Also ich nutze hier immer ganz gern das Premium Backblech.
Ihr könnt es so herum oder auch andersherum nehmen.
Dann eine Dauerbackfolie und der Herzring oder die Herzbackform.
Hier jetzt einfüllen und dann im vorgeheizten Ofen backen.
Bei der Herzform ist es so:
Sie ersetzt eine Springform im Durchmesser von 28 cm.
Das heißt, ihr könnt jetzt z. B. auch, wenn ihr sagt
„Mama liebt einfach die Schwarzwälder Kirschtorte“,
dann geht ihr einfach in die Sallys App,
wählt die Schwarzwälder Kirschtorte an,
ändert dann den Durchmesser der Torte auf 28 cm
und habt dann die perfekte Menge für diese Backform ausgerechnet.
So könnt ihr es mit jeder Torte machen.
Also ihr könnt wirklich jede Torte, die ihr gerne mögt,
die es auch schon auf meinem Blog gibt,
einfach in meiner App auf 28 cm umrechnen lassen.
Falls es bei mir eine Torte noch nicht gibt, die ihr gern mögt,
könnt ihr einfach den Zutatenumrechner nutzen,
dort alle Zutaten eintragen und dann auch auf 28 cm umrechnen.
[Musik]
Biskuit mag ich so gern, weil er schnell backt.
Er braucht jetzt bei mir nur 18 Minuten,
kann aber sein – je nach Backofen,
dass er bei euch 2-3 Minuten länger oder kürzer braucht.
[Musik]
[Uhr]
Die Backzeit nutze ich jetzt natürlich auch
und mache schon einmal weiter.
Ich habe mich für eine Buttercreme entschieden,
weil es heute einfach etwas schneller gehen soll.
Ich muss auch sagen,
ich kann die Buttercreme von Decocino sehr empfehlen.
Sie geht schnell – ich mache später noch ein Drip darüber.
Deswegen ist es auch ganz gut,
wenn ich jetzt eine Buttercreme zubereite.
Alternativ zur Packung könnt ihr aber auch einen Pudding herstellen,
ganz klassisch mit Milch, Zucker und etwas Stärke
und dann eine Buttercreme herstellen.
Oder wenn ihr sagt „Buttercreme geht gar nicht!“,
könnt ihr auch eine Quark- oder Mascarponesahnecreme machen.
Aber wie gesagt, für den Zweck heute ist sie sehr gut
und mir schmeckt sie auch hervorragend.
Ich nehme dafür
1 Päckchen Buttercreme, 250 ml Wasser und 300 g weiche Butter.
Statt Wasser könnt ihr auch ganz gern
schon einmal Geschmack mit hineinbringen.
Die Buttercreme an sich schmeckt sehr schön
und sehr lecker nach Vanille.
Ich mag es gern!
Ihr könnt aber z. B. auch einen Kaffee rauslassen
und eine Kaffeebuttercreme machen.
Ihr könnt Saft und auch Milch verwenden.
Also da könnt ihr wirklich den Geschmack auch etwas steuern.
Ihr könnt auch die Vanillecreme lassen
und dazu noch eine Zitronenschale mit dazu abreiben.
Aber ich mache sie jetzt ganz klassisch
und werde später dann bei der Fruchtfüllung
noch etwas mehr Geschmack mit einbringen.
Im ersten Schritt – deswegen setze ich es auch direkt schon an,
denn die Creme muss ein bisschen ziehen.
Das heißt, ich habe hier mein Cremepulver,
füge dann die Flüssigkeit dazu – in meinem Fall Wasser.
Jetzt kurz verrühren.
Dann darf das Ganze etwa 30 Minuten lang quellen.
Das wird dann auch so ein bisschen kleisterartig.
Die Stäke darin quillt jetzt einfach,
sodass diese Creme schön fest wird.
Es ist also im Prinzip wie so eine klassische deutsche Buttercreme,
die man mit Pudding macht,
nur dass man den Pudding nicht aufkochen muss.
Das ist der Vorteil.
Die lasse ich hier jetzt stehen.
Sobald sie dann schon etwa 20 Minuten steht,
kann ich die weiche Butter nehmen,
gebe sie hier rein und verrühre sie schön weißcremig.
Das dauert etwa 10-15 Minuten.
[Musik]
Jetzt ist die Butter schön weißcremig.
Da solltet ihr auch wirklich darauf achten,
damit sie auch diesen typischen Buttergeschmack verliert.
Also ruhig 10-15 Minuten lang rühren!
Ich habe jetzt hier die Buttercrememasse.
Sie sieht ein bisschen unappetitlich aus – wie Kleister -,
aber wie gesagt, das ist normal und es gehört so.
Es ist ja im Prinzip auch einfach nur
Wasser, Stärke und Zucker mit Vanille.
Also anstelle von Milchpudding einfach ein Pudding ohne Milch.
Den rühre ich jetzt einmal kurz durch
und kann ihn löffelweise einrühren.
[Musik]
So ist sie jetzt richtig schön luftig.
Wenn eure Küche sehr warm ist,
dürft ihr sie gern in den Kühlschrank stellen,
kurz, bis es weitergeht.
Ansonsten könnt ihr sie aber auch bei Raumtemperatur stehenlassen,
denn jetzt werde ich noch einen No-bake-Boden herstellen.
Das müsst ihr nicht machen, aber ich finde,
ein bisschen Geschmack könnt ihr schon noch zusätzlich hineinbringen,
und vor allem ein bisschen Crunch.
Da mache ich ganz besonders einen Ruby No-bake-Boden.
Habe ich gerade Ruby? (Deutsch ausgesprochen)
„Ruby“ Schokolade! (Amerikanisch ausgesprochen).
Erkläre ich euch gleich.
Der Biskuit ist jetzt abgekühlt.
Jetzt kann ich ihn herauslösen.
Ich habe ihn tatsächlich in der Form abkühlen lassen,
habe hier ein Backformmesser.
Es hat hier zwei Klingen,
nämlich die eine Klinge
– sie ist unten auch nicht spitz, sondern eher abgerundet –
sie löst innen den Tortenrand
und die andere hält das Messer an der Form fest.
Jetzt denkt ihr einfach daran,
ihr geht mit dem Messer zwischen die Backform
und drückt aber jetzt auch ein bisschen dagegen.
Damit ihr die Backfolie nicht durchlöchert,
zieht ihr sie am besten vorher runter,
was ich jetzt fast vergessen hätte.
Jetzt drückt ihr die Klinge immer schön an die Backform ran,
denn so kann man den Biskuit am schönsten ablösen.
[Musik]
Dann die Backfolie darunter wegrollen.
Deswegen lasse ich da auch immer gern noch den Rand dran,
denn am Ende kann ich an der Backform festhalten und wegziehen.
[Musik]
Diesen stelle ich jetzt kurz zur Seite.
Er kann noch ein bisschen fertig auskühlen.
Hier noch ein kleiner Putztrick:
Wenn ihr jetzt auch auf der Backfolie Rückstände habt,
könnt ihr sie natürlich mit dem Schwamm wegnehmen
oder was noch einfach und besser ist,
damit der Schwamm auch nicht so teigig wird
- denn ich muss immer den Schwamm wegschmeißen; sobald Teig dranklebt,
dann sammeln sich Bakterien daran.
Oder ihr nehmt ein Silikonschwamm,
aber ich kratze das Ganze meist so erst einmal weg.
Dann habt ihr die groben Bestandteile schon entfernt.
Dann könnt ihr die Backfolie mit einem Spülschwamm reinigen.
Also, wie gesagt, habe ich jetzt hier die Ruby Schokolade.
Das ist die vierte Schokoladensorte neben den übrigen,
also neben weißer, Vollmilch- und Zartbitterschokolade.
Sie ist ganz besonders, hat einen schönen fruchtigen Geschmack.
Deswegen finde ich, passt sie ganz gut zum Muttertag.
Die weißen Perlen sind kleine Schokoladenperlen
aus weißer Schokolade.
Da ist eine Art Keks mit dabei.
Deswegen wird es jetzt ein richtig schöner, leckerer Boden.
Dafür nehme ich
200 g Ruby Schokolade, 100 g Butterkekse, 80 g Mandeln (gehackte),
50 g weiße Perlen und 3 EL Himbeeren (gefriergetrocknet).
Was ihr jetzt hier machen könnt:
Die Kuvertüre entweder über einem warmen Wasserbad schmelzen
oder einfach in der Mikrowelle.
So mache ich das jetzt kurz.
Ich schmelze das Ganze immer 1 Minute, rühre kurz durch,
schmelze weiter, rühre wieder durch.
Im Prinzip braucht ihr sie nur ungefähr bis zur Hälfte schmelzen,
nehmt sie dann heraus und rührt sie durch,
denn durch die Restwärme schmelzen die übrigen auch.
[Musik]
In der Zwischenzeit kann ich schon einmal die Kekse zerkleinern.
Das könnt ihr mit einem Mörser machen,
mit einem Ausrollstab, Händen oder einfach mit einem Zerstampfer.
[Musik]
Wenn ihr merkt, das ist noch nicht flüssig genug,
einfach noch einmal zum Schmelzen in die Mikrowelle geben,
aber darauf achten, dass ihr die Temperatur nicht zu heiß einstellt.
[Musik]
Die Himbeeren könnt ihr jetzt auch mit zerkleinern
Weil sie gefriergetrocknet sind,
kann man sie ganz gut einfach zerbröseln.
[Musik]
So ist sie jetzt perfekt.
Bei mir waren es 3 Minuten bei 600 Watt.
Aber je nach Mikrowelle kann es auch ein bisschen kürzer ausfallen.
Also lieber vorher reinschauen.
[Musik]
Sehr schön!
Da kommen jetzt einfach alle übrigen Zutaten rein.
Wenn ihr möchtet, könnt ihr die Mandeln vorher auch noch rösten.
Dann sind sie noch intensiver im Geschmack.
Die weißen Schokoladenperlen gebe ich erst zum Schluss rein,
denn die Ruby Schokolade ist ja jetzt ein bisschen warm
- damit die weiße Schokolade nicht schmilzt.
Daher wirklich erst am Ende dazugeben.
[Musik]
Jetzt nehme ich mir einen Tortenretter
- [lacht] mir hat kurz das Wort gefehlt -,
eine Backfolie darüber und noch einmal die Herzform.
Diese würde ich einfach kurz vorher auswaschen,
damit sie wieder schön sauber ist.
Dann kann hier nämlich der Crunch-Boden eingefüllt werden.
[Musik]
Jetzt einfach schön verteilen und flach drücken.
Ich verteile es immer erst grob,
damit überall ungefähr die gleiche Menge liegt.
Dann könnt zum Festdrücken ein Glas, eine Burgerpresse,
so eine tiefe Palette oder die Hände nehmen,
aber da klebt sie nur ein bisschen an.
Daher ist ein Glas oder eine Burgerpresse ganz gut geeignet.
Ich finde es immer gut, wenn man Werkzeug hat,
was einen Doppelnutzen hat,
weil ich backe öfter No-bake-Böden als dass ich Burger mache.
Ist schon ein Fakt!
Die Burgerpresse ist zu 1/10 eine Burgerpresse
und zu 9/10 ein Tortenzubehör.
[Musik]
Jetzt die Fugenmasse schön verspachteln. [Lacht]
Schon so ein bisschen wie auf der Baustelle.
Glattziehen und den Silikonrand – nein Quatsch!
Jetzt kommt das Ganze in den Kühlschrank
oder, wenn es schneller gehen muss, ins Gefrierfach.
[Musik]
Ihr könnt jetzt den Tortenboden einmal halbieren.
Ich habe hier eine Marmelade, und zwar
- okay, es klingt ein bisschen komisch,
aber ich habe jetzt alle Reste aus dem Kühlschrank,
die angefallen sind, zusammengesucht,
aber das ist immer die beste Marmelade.
Aprikose, Himbeere, Erdbeere,
schwarze Johannisbeere habe ich noch mit drin.
Wenn ihr möchtet, könnt ihr auch noch einen Likör,
ein bisschen Himbeergeist oder ein bisschen Tonka Wonka dazugeben,
denn die Tonkabohne passt sehr gut dazu.
Ihr könnt aber auch 1 Prise Tonkabohne dazu reiben.
Jetzt kommt hier ein wenig Marmelade auf den No-bake-Boden.
Jetzt nicht bis ganz zum Rand streichen,
sondern eher mittig bleiben, dass es nicht hinausquillt.
Dann lege den ersten Boden hinein.
Da nehme ich einfach den Deckel, drehe ihn um.
[Musik]
Man hört einfach, wie locker der Biskuit ist. Sehr schön!
Noch einmal Marmelade.
[Musik]
Dann kommt jetzt hier eine dünne Schicht Buttercreme darauf.
Da nehme ich auch eine saubere Palette.
Ihr könnt die andere auch kurz säubern,
aber ich finde es immer gut,
wenn die Schichten sich nicht zu sehr durchmischen
und da jetzt nicht die Marmelade mit draufgestrichen wird.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich noch den zweiten Boden.
Da kommt jetzt noch die übrige Marmelade darauf, wird verstrichen
und dann kann ich ihn mit der Marmeladenseite
nach unten auf die Torte setzen.
Dann ist sie schön im Inneren und gut verschlossen.
[Musik]
Leicht andrücken.
Dann kommt noch einmal eine dünne Schicht oben darauf.
[Musik]
Diese streiche ich jetzt so glatt wie möglich,
also jetzt schon ein bisschen Mühe geben.
Aber ein bisschen Buttercreme habe ich noch übrig.
Diese brauche ich nämlich dann für den Rand,
aber kann jetzt erst einmal die Torte kühlen,
damit ich sie gleich aus der Form herausholen kann.
Deswegen muss ich sagen,
gerade bei Torten, die etwas schneller gehen sollen oder müssen,
finde ich es ganz gut, wenn man mit einer Buttercreme arbeitet,
da die Butter dann einfach auch schön fest wird
und man kann schneller daran weiter dekorieren.
Gerade bei so einer Torte mit einem Drip ist eine Buttercreme schon
immer etwas praktischer als eine Quarksahnetorte.
Dann kommt sie für mindestens 1 Stunde in den Kühlschrank,
oder 30 Minuten im Gefrierfach ist auch möglich.
Ihr könnt sie auch gern 2 Stunden im Kühlschrank lassen.
Je länger, umso besser.
Die übrige Creme werde ich jetzt auch kühlstellen,
weil es bei uns in der Küche wirklich sehr warm ist.
Ansonsten aber, wie gesagt, kann sie bei Raumtemperatur stehen.
Ui, fast hätte ich die Unterlage nicht mitgezogen.
[Musik und Uhr]
Jetzt ziehe ich die Backfolie unter der Torte weg
und kann die Backform lösen.
[Musik]
Oh, die ist so schön!
Jetzt nehmt ihr einfach die restliche Buttercreme,
die ihr habt, und könnt sie am Rand verstreichen
und auch schön die Oberfläche glätten.
Ich finde es auch ganz schön,
wenn die Torte nicht ganz verschlossen wird [lacht],
sondern wenn sie so Semi-naked ist.
Also Naked-Cake wäre ja im Prinzip so,
dass sie im Prinzip einfach komplett glatt und nackt bleibt.
Semi-naked ist so,
dass man so ein bisschen noch die Struktur und die Böden durchsieht.
Das könnt ihr auch gern machen. Das ist auch schön!
Ich muss jetzt hier beim Aufstreichen nur aufpassen,
weil die Torte durch diesen Crunch-Boden ein bisschen rutscht.
Wenn euch das ein bisschen zu unsicher ist,
streicht ein bisschen Buttercreme auf den Tortenretter
und setzt dann den Boden auf.
Dann klebt das Ganze ein bisschen fest.
Aber guckt mal, wenn ich hier ein bisschen fester drücke,
seht ihr, dann verschiebt sich die Torte.
[Musik]
Wenn ihr rundherum dann erst einmal die Creme aufgetragen habt,
könnt ihr euch eine Teigkarte nehmen.
Sie hat hier so einen schönen rechten Winkel,
so wie die Torte auch am Rand.
Ihr könnt im Prinzip
– ich fange vorn an der Spitze an
und könnt dann die Creme glattziehen.
Vielleicht fangt ihr doch in der Mitte an
und könnt sie zur Spitze hinunter glattziehen,
einmal so herum, einmal andersherum.
[Musik]
Jetzt ist die Oberfläche so, wie ich sie haben möchte.
Jetzt im Prinzip einfach noch einmal, wie gerade eben,
einmal den Rand glattziehen.
[Musik]
Dann einfach von außen nach innen streichen.
Dann sind die Ränder auch schön.
Kleine Feinheiten mache ich immer gern noch mit einer kleinen Palette,
aber im Grunde ist die Torte jetzt schon sehr schön.
Ich stelle sie jetzt noch einmal ganz kurz in den Kühlschrank,
damit die oberste Cremeschicht
auch noch einmal schön glatt und vor allem fest ist.
Wenn ihr noch Feinheiten habt, die ihr ausbessern wollt,
stellt sie jetzt lieber erst einmal für 15 Minuten kühl
und dann könnt ihr mit der Restcreme dran herumarbeiten.
In der Zeit kann ich mich schon einmal
um die Schokoladenglasur kümmern.
Also geht doch sehr schnell.
[Musik]
Für den Schokoladen-Drip nehme ich
90 g Sahne, etwas Kokosöl und 150 g Zartbitterkuvertüre.
Zuerst lasse ich die Sahne kochen, direkt mit dem Kokosfett.
[Musik]
Komm, ich mache einen auf Sturmi.
Ich gehe auf Power Boost.
Apropos Sturmi,
ich finde, es wird wieder Zeit, dass Sturmi nominiert wird.
Liebster Freddie, ich nominiere dich hiermit ganz offiziell
zum Nachbacken dieser Muttertagstorte.
Nimm das Postpaket an!
Ich schicke dir etwas, zumindest die Herzform,
dass er etwas backen kann.
Ah, ich freue mich schon auf dein Video!
Grüß alle ganz lieb in der Familie von mir!
[Musik]
Back eine schöne, leckere Torte!
So, dann den Herd ausschalten.
[Lacht] Es macht mir immer Spaß, den Sturmi zu nominieren.
Er kriegt dann immer eine kurze Schockstarre:
„Oh, Sally hat mich nominiert!“
Dann hat er aber voll den Spaß beim Backen.
Die Sahne ist gekocht, den Herd habe ich ausgeschaltet.
Jetzt kann ich die Kuvertüre einrühren.
[Musik]
Wenn sich dann die Schokolade schön aufgelöst hat,
gieße ich das Ganze in eine Dosierflasche um.
Damit werde ich jetzt die Glasur dosieren.
Ihr könnt sie aber auch gleich
mit einem Löffel oder mit einem Spritzbeutel über die Torte tropfen
[Musik]
Ihr könnt in der Flasche die Glasur ganz schnell abkühlen.
Einfach unter das kalte Wasser halten.
[Musik]
Ich habe jetzt hier eine Tortenplatte für die Torte
und setze sie um, bevor ich sie fertig dekoriere.
[Musik]
Dann kann ich sie noch einmal auf die Drehplatte setzen.
Wie gesagt, bei der Torte ein bisschen vorsichtig sein.
Sie rutscht nämlich durch den No-bake-Boden.
Jetzt habe ich hier zum Fertigdekorieren zum einen
meine Schokoladenglasur, Erdbeeren, Himbeeren,
Brombeeren und Blaubeeren.
Für den tollen Geschmack und die Optik habe ich
die weißen Schokoladenperlen, Ruby Schokoladenperlen
und noch weiße Schokoladenstreusel.
Dunkle Schokoladenstreusel und Vollmilch kennt ihr wahrscheinlich.
Weiße, muss ich sagen, hatte ich bisher auch noch nicht,
aber ich finde sie sehr schön, denn sie schmecken einfach
sehr, sehr lecker nach guter weißer Schokolade.
Jetzt werde ich hier die Erdbeeren halbieren oder vierteln,
je nach Größe.
Wenn ihr bis hierhergekommen seid,
dann ist es schon einmal ganz gut,
denn jetzt habt ihr eigentlich die Torte schon fertig.
Jetzt wird sie nur noch fertig dekoriert.
STURMI: Bist schon wieder zu Hause?
SALLY: Hallo!
Ja, ich war schnell essen und bin wieder daheim, weiter backen.
STURMI: Hä? Was backst du? Das ist die Torte?
SALLY: Ich backe das, was du auch bald backst. [Lacht]
STURMI: Ich habe das nur so aus den Augenwinkeln gesehen.
Das ist ja voll anstrengend!
SALLY: Es wird gut.
STURMI: Bei mir sieht es dann aus wie ein Popo.
Ich sehe nämlich schon das Gebogene
und ich mache dann einfach ein Backen mit Popo.
SALLY: Sieht nicht aus wie ein Popo!
Das sieht dann aus wie ein Herz.
STURMI: Grüße alle ganz doll
SALLY: Auch ganz liebe Grüße von uns.
STURMI: Ich vermisse euch.
MIGUEL: Ich auch!
SALLY: Wir vermissen euch auch.
MIGUEL: Ja, ist blöd. Ich hasse das alles!
SALLY: Ich halte schon das Gästezimmer für bessere Zeiten bereit.
STURMI: Ja, Miguel und ich kommen dann vorbei
und machen es so wie beim letzten Mal, ja Miguel? [Sally stimmt zu]
Das ist Teamwork.
SALLY: Seid ihr auch dafür, dass Sturmi wieder kommt? Ich schon!
JOSH: Jaaa!
SALLY: Mit Miguel.
Die Abstimmung habe ich gesehen: 100 % Ja! [Lacht]
So machen wir das.
Okay, also du bekommst in den nächsten Tagen Post, ja?
STURMI: Ich freu mich.
SALLY: [Lacht] Viel Spaß!
STURMI: Danke!
SALLY: Tschüss!
STURMI UND MIGUEL: Ciao!
SALLY: [Lacht] 10 € so eine Dose!
Sturmi hat die Nominierung angenommen.
Er wird diese Torte auch backen.
Ich werde ihm heute noch ein Paket rausschicken,
damit er alles hat und keine Ausreden findet,
dass er sie eben nicht machen kann.
Also, jetzt nehmt ihr die Glasur.
Sie ist jetzt schön, wie sage ich jetzt, handwarm.
Ihr könnt das auch immer ganz gut,
falls ihr nicht wisst, ob die Glasur kalt genug ist,
könnt ihr z. B. ein Glas nehmen
und das einfach einmal am Glas entlang runterlaufen lassen.
Ich sehe jetzt schon, der Tropfen wird langsamer
und die Torte ist ja kalt.
Das heißt, auf der Torte wird die Glasur natürlich schön fest
und sie ist jetzt nicht zu flüssig.
Jetzt könnt ihr hier schön diese Drips runterlaufen lassen,
in einem Abstand, den ihr gern selbst wählt.
[Musik]
Dann ziehe die Glasur innen noch ein bisschen entlang.
Ihr könnt natürlich auch
die komplette Oberfläche der Torte mit der Glasur überziehen.
Ich muss allerdings sagen, ich finde es auch schön,
wenn die Mittel hell bleibt und nur der Rest drumherum dunkel ist.
Dann nehmt ihr nämlich einfach so eine kleine Palette,
zieht das ein bisschen nach hinten glatt.
Ich schau dann außen immer noch, ob mir die Drips gefallen
oder ob es noch welche gibt, die ich länger haben möchte,
aber so passt es jetzt für mich.
Die Oberfläche dekoriere ich in der Herzform
mit den ganzen Früchten und den Perlen.
[Musik]
So sieht jetzt also die Torte aus
und ich würde sagen...
ELA: Ich hab‘ dich gehört. Ich hab‘ dich gesehen.
[Sally lacht]
SALLY: Komm, du darfst probieren.
Und, wie findest du sie als Muttertagstorte?
ELA: Schön!
SALLY: Schön? [Ela stimmt zu]
Sehr gut.
Du darfst übrigens mit mir mit zum ZDF-Fernsehgarten.
ELA: Yaaay!
SALLY: Dann verbringen wir den Muttertag dort zusammen, ok?
[Ela stimmt zu]
Gut!
Wenn ihr möchtet – es gibt auch noch diese Holz Cake Topper -,
könnt ihr sie auch nehmen, finde ich nämlich auch süß.
Da gibt es z. B. ein „Danke“ oder „Für dich“.
Nein, wir nehmen es heute nicht, weil ich kein Danke gefunden habe.
„Thank you“ wollte ich jetzt nicht,
weil die Oma ja kein [flüstert] Englisch kann. Deswegen.
„Teşekkür ederim“ gibt es ja nicht. Egal.
Aber z. B. „Danke“, „Alles Gute“ oder „Für dich“ wäre ganz schön.
ELA: Aber wir müssen mal kurz „Thank you“ ausprobieren.
SALLY: Nein. Ich würde sagen,
wir probieren jetzt einfach einmal die Torte.
ELA: Ich mach das!
SALLY: Oh! Komm, wir schneiden sie zusammen an.
Vielleicht hier. Warte!
Wir müssen immer so ein bisschen mitdenken,
weil die Sarah dann noch die Bilder macht.
Oh, jetzt muss dir kurz helfen. Da unten ist ja ein Crunch-Boden.
ELA: Richtig mit Kraft.
SALLY: Oh Gott, das kriege ich mit dem stumpfen Messer gar nicht hin.
[Lacht]
Achtung Schatz, Finger!
Ich habe ganz vergessen, dass da der Crunch-Boden drin ist.
So, und hier...
ELA: Oh ja, das sieht schön aus! So ein schöner Schnitt.
SALLY: Ist das schön?
ELA: Das sieht so aus wie ein dickes Herz.
SALLY: Und?
ELA: Gut!
[Sally lacht]
Sieht toll aus!
SALLY: Ja?
ELA: Ja! Die schönste Torte, die ich je gesehen habe.
SALLY: Oh! Und du bist das süßeste Kind, was ich je gesehen habe.
Warte, warte! Du hängst an mir.
Wie kann man nur so süß sein!
ELA: Ich habe am Mikrofon gehangen.
SALLY: [Lacht] Ja, du hast am Mikrofon gehangen
Oh, du bist so eine süße Maus!
Hast du das jetzt nur so gesagt
oder ist das wirklich die schönste Torte, die du je gesehen hast?
ELA: Das ist die schönste!
SALLY: Ich hoffe, es ist auch die leckerste.
ELA: Hmm! Gut! Lecker!
SALLY: Mmh!
ELA: Das schmeckt voll lecker mit dem Crunch-Boden. [Sally stimmt zu]
Ich probiere jetzt erstmal von hinten aus.
SALLY: Boah, die ist echt lecker!
Ich meine, wenn ihr die Zeit habt und sagt,
ihr nehmt keine fertige Marmelade,
sondern ihr püriert vielleicht Früchte und kocht sie ein,
könnt ihr da ein bisschen mehr Säure dazu geben.
Eine Marmelade ist natürlich
ein bisschen süßer als zerdrückte Früchte.
Also ich ganz persönlich hätte jetzt wahrscheinlich
sogar Früchte eher noch püriert, zerdrückt und eingekocht
und sie dann ein bisschen sauer in den Kuchen reingestrichen
Aber auch so ist die Torte sehr lecker!
Denkst du, die Zuschauer sollten die Torte nachmachen?
Ja? [Ela stimmt zu]
Also sprichst du dein Lob aus?
Okay!
Und wenn ich jetzt sage, der Sturmi der Sturmwaffel
backt die Torte auch noch - meinst du, er schafft das?
ELA: Ja!
SALLY: Willst du ihm noch etwas ausrichten?
ELA: Liebe Grüße.
SALLY: Komm, guck mal in die Kamera. Dann kannst du sie ihm ausrichten.
ELA: Liebe Grüße an Sturmi
SALLY: Oh! Viele Grüße!
Also euch viel Spaß beim Backen.
Wie gesagt, am Sonntag kommt noch eine Muttertagsidee von Murat,
aber ich denke, da freut sich doch jede Mama darüber, oder?
ELA: Ja!
SALLY: Glaubst du, die Oma wird sich auch über die Torte freuen?
[Ela stimmt zu]
Ja, oder? Ihr backen wir dann auch eine zum Muttertag.
Viel Spaß beim Nachbacken!
Bis zum nächsten Mal! Tschüss!
Und wo findet man das Rezept?
ELA: Auf Sallys-Blog.de
SALLY: Oder?
ELA: In deiner App.
SALLY: Ganz genau. Tschüss!
Und wo gehen wir zwei jetzt hin?
Komm, wir gehen jetzt raus!
ELA: Ja! Jetzt habe ich meine erste Reitstunde verpasst.
SALLY: Ja, komm! Du kannst auf mir reiten.
Ich nehme dich Huckepack.
ELA: Nö!
SALLY: Nö!
[Sally und Mitarbeiter aus dem Hintergrund lachen]
[Musik]